hello everyone thanks so much for asking
me here nice tent really nice big town
I'll be really brief the crown the
Netflix miniseries that was on earlier
this year depicting a decade in the
early life of queenless but the second
was they say the most lavish and
expensive I think TV series that has
appeared on our screens it was made even
more remarkable by the presence of the
woman who played Princess Margaret's I
was lucky enough to be on that show and
to get to meet and work with this most
brilliant remarkable witty fun-loving
warm-hearted actress it gives me huge
enormous intense pleasure to present the
2017 Glamour TV actress of the Year
awards to Her Royal greatness the
unstoppable Vanessa Kirby so many
amazing people here I come hani believe
this is happening and my mum wants to
say hi to frank lampard over there
but she wasn't over the courage yeah hi
um what was I gonna say so many things
um you know what um thank you camera and
thank you Joe Alvin I remember reading
the first issue when glamour first came
out and it's always been such an amazing
presence of my life and was always
champion women so this is so amazing and
also so much more of an honor cos guys I
had the best time of my whole life on
this show and it changed me as a person
and it was amazing to play a woman who
always fought for change despite her
circumstance and was that a [ __ ] good
time doing it yeah I can't tell you how
many Hubble cigarettes I smoke I mean I
know this is why I've got really no more
time um but also you know to be in a
show where women are at the center of it
and we're not in relationship to the men
well I'm not the fired fiancee of you
your violent fiancee and me I can't say
don't sound so nervous
and that was an amazing sort of feeling
to have that and also that it became or
even about gender that a woman was in
power but a human being was in power and
it was no longer a differentiation so it
changed me as a human being and I had to
thank Claire for you as an amazing
leader of the show also dead not still
my sister over there he's my best friend
and I gave her nose bead because I made
her cry so hard once I'm really sorry
for that that's the big regret in my
life and my mom who's also supported me
from the very beginning and gave birth
her Fanny and I'm gonna go now thank you